مخزونات القوات الاوكرانيه تجف شيئا تشتكي
كيف من قنابل جويه روسيه معدله جديده من
طراز اف اي بي فايف حيث حذرت اوكرانيا من
استخدام روسيا لقنابل ذكيه موجهه مثل فاب
5 في الاشهر الاخيره هذه القنابل وزنها
500 كيلوغرام تسقط في الجو براس حربي شديد
الانفجار القنبله غير موجهه وهي متوافقه
مع معظم الطائرات السوفيتيه تم تجهيزها
بوحده تخطيط وتصحيح تحول القنابل العاديه
تحول القنابل العاديه الى قنبله عاليه
الدقه ما اعطى الطائرات الروسيه من طراز
سوق
34.35 القدره على تحييد انظمه الدفاع
الجويه الاوكرانيه من خلال اطلاق 20 قنبله
موجهه يوميا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات